Der Winterhimmel in der Neujahrsnacht,
generiert von zehn Videobeamern
und Hochleistungscomputern
im Zeiss-Planetarium in Berlin.
Die Weiten des Weltalls werden
gerade auch 2018 gründlich erforscht.
Geben uns die Sterne auch einen Wink,
wie es persönlich weitergeht?
Anders als die Astronomie vermutet
das seit Jahrtausenden die Astrologie.
2018 steht im Zeichen der Venus.
Das heißt, dass alle Menschen
darauf aus sind,
sich wirklich verstehen zu wollen
und auch nicht dauernd
gegeneinander zu kämpfen.
Also, das ist das Jahr der Liebe,
der Sinnlichkeit, der Schönheit.
Das heißt, die Leute werden alle die
Gelegenheit bekommen,
ihre eigene Venus stark in (die) Richtung
(in) Zusammenarbeit zu gehen
und sich zu harmonisieren.
Aber es wird im neuen Jahr nicht nur
harmonisch sein.
Der Planet Uranus könnte für
Turbulenzen sorgen.
Wir haben noch eine extreme
Konstellation
und zwar wechselt tatsächlich auch
noch der Uranus in den Stier.
Das heißt, diese Stierkonstellation,
wenn der Uranus da eintritt,
gibt’s eine kleine Revolution.
Also, es ist sehr gut möglich, dass der
Euro da ins Wackeln kommt.
Das ist die große Frage, wie lange
(es) der dann macht.
Also, mit Sicherheit wird er auf jeden
Fall noch bleiben.
Knapp ein Viertel der Deutschen
glaubt an die Sterndeutung.
Bei wichtigen persönlichen
Entscheidungen werden die Sterne befragt.
Wenn der Astrologe gut analysieren kann,
dann ist das so ’ne Art Lebenshilfe,
die man verwenden kann,
um auf einige Situationen vielleicht
besser einzugehen.
Spirituell und religiös geprägte Menschen
blicken übrigens mit Zuversicht
in die Zukunft,
so neueste Umfragen.
Der Berliner Buchladen „Daulat“ leistet
dazu einen Beitrag.
Hier gibt es Ratgeber, Tarotkarten
oder Räucherwaren,
um zuhause böse Geister zu vertreiben.
Man kann das Leben nicht zurückdrehen,
aber man kann am Jahresanfang
(kann man) neu anfangen,
in was für ‘ner Art auch immer.
Also, ich beobachte, dass viele Leute
gerne mal so ‘n Hausputz machen,
ausräuchern, da gibt’s hier diverse Stoffe.
Dem Mond wird eine magische Kraft
zugesprochen, aber auch Steinen.
Nach Meinung mancher können sie
sogar heilend wirken.
Überhaupt: Gesünder leben ist der
Klassiker unter den guten Vorsätzen
für das neue Jahr.
Obst und Gemüse stehen zu
Jahresbeginn hoch im Kurs.
Also, ich denke, es ist auf jeden Fall
sehr wichtig,
auch für den Körper und immer
schön fit zu bleiben.
Obst und Gemüse ist immer
Anziehfaktor hier im Laden.
Ein weiterer guter Vorsatz: mehr Sport.
Nach reichhaltigem Essen zu
Weihnachten und Silvester
wollen viele abspecken.
Einige stecken sich noch höhere Ziele.
Für mich ist Sport im neuen Jahr
sehr wichtig,
denn ich habe mir vorgenommen,
einen Marathon zu laufen,
und um das zu schaffen, treibe ich
verschiedene Sportarten.
Das Start-Up „Urban Sports Club“
vermittelt seine Mitglieder an
verschiedene Fitness-Studios.
Die besinnliche, ruhige Weihnachtszeit
ist zu Ende.
Dementsprechend nehmen sich
viele Leute vor,
jetzt was für die Gesundheit zu tun,
sich mehr zu bewegen
und entsprechend merken wir das natürlich
bei den Anmeldungen im Januar und Februar.
44 Prozent der Deutschen
blicken einer Umfrage zufolge
optimistisch in die Zukunft.
Viele haben Vorsätze oder konkrete Wünsche:
Ich wünsche mir für 2018
ein bisschen mehr Frieden.
Dass ich gesund bleibe, meinen Job
behalte. Die Liebe finde.
Vielleicht mehr reisen?
Ich fände es toll, wenn ich weniger
Kaffee trinke.
Ich will weniger in den sozialen Medien
unterwegs sein, aber das ist schwer.
Welche Vorsätze und Wünsche sich
2018 wirklich erfüllen,
das steht in den Sternen.